well as I was growing up I was always
interested in math and always interested
in the world around me natural phenomena
that tended to express itself in being
interested in things in nature so I
would collect live bumblebees and do
experiments with them that related to
changing their diets their habitats the
amount of Sun light and darkness they
were exposed to then i would add in
wasps and yellow jackets and i tried to
understand how the different species
behaved levels of aggression what
changed with diet and i'd keep very
detailed notebooks and then i'd keep
them in jars lined up under our back
porch we had a crawl space and but as I
went along I got more and more
interested on the mathematics side and
things that relate it to the physical
world although I really didn't decide to
become a physicist until I was a
freshman in college
one I think we can just introduce young
people early on to the wonders and the
beauty of science and its ability to
help them understand things to explain
things to do hands-on as well as mines
on kinds of activities early on to build
that both formally into the curricula in
K through 12 education but also outside
of classroom experiences including
making use of more community-based
resources like museums and the like we
have to excite them that's the point we
have to excite them about the wonders of
the natural world we have to invite them
by letting them know that they too can
become scientists or engineers or work
in these fields or at least have an
understanding of what science is and
what it does but also have people
understand that there are interesting
pathways and good ones today for careers
and that they get to work on really cool
stuff and really important things and I
think all of these are the ways but then
if we want to go beyond that to look at
more structural issues the single most
important rate-limiting step has to do
with having good teachers because a good
teacher makes all the difference in a
young person's life and so we have to
then have teachers who are well-prepared
who if they were not educated in the
sciences and engineering are have
professional development programs that
can bring them more up to speed on these
things we have to have more degree
teachers teachers with actual degrees in
science mathematics and engineering and
so really having good teachers well
prepared teachers and we should hold up
the best examples the the best teachers
and what they do in and have more
testimony to that effect but then the
media has a role in terms of how
scientists and engineers and
mathematicians are portrayed and they
mathematicians tend to be portrayed in a
somewhat exaggerated way in the media
now one could argue that all characters
in a fictional story have some degree of
exaggeration of whatever their
characteristics are but I think we've
tended to have a somewhat distorted view
although problems like numbers I find
pretty pretty interesting because they
kind of changed the construct of it but
but I think the media has a role I think
obviously parents but in the end
teachers strong curricula and then
holding up examples whether it's the
google guys or the person who helped to
decode DNA these are the kinds of things
that I think can all help but
preparation is what is always needed
because to do science takes a cumulative
background you can't do advanced
mathematics if you don't know calculus
if you don't know trigonometry geometry
algebra and you certainly can't do those
things if you can't add subtract
multiply divide know fractions etc